bonsoir bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo avec la loi la réforme du
travail en france
pour nous cette question en europe
va-t-on vers plus de flexibilité
l'europe est-elle encore social en
première partie direction la grèce ça
n'a pas été accepté par tout le monde
ici gaz lacrymogène contre cocktails
molotov mais c'est passé parlement grec
a adopté une réforme du régime des
retraites et de l'impôt sur le revenu ça
représente près de 3 milliards
d'économies par an la grèce fait des
efforts pour espérer obtenir le
versement de 5 à 7 milliards d'euros
prévus par le plan de sauvetage européen
et puis généralement en europe si le
chômage a légèrement baissé dans la zone
euro à ils touchent encore un européen
sur dix en âge de travailler la lutte
contre le chômage c'est la préoccupation
majeure des européens nous irons en
suède
là-bas pour lutter contre le chômage on
teste la semaine de 30 heures au travail
six heures de travail par jour c'est le
cas dans certaines entreprises et même
dans les services municipaux de la ville
de göteborg la deuxième ville du pays et
le cp s'est rendu sur place réduction du
temps de travail flexibilité l'europe
est-elle encore social ces questions les
posera nos invités robert rochefort
eurodéputés vice président du modem et
emmanuel maurel eurodéputés socialistes
mais d'abord direction la grèce les
européens font un pas en direction
d'alexis tsipras ce l'eurogroupe a salué
les dernières réformes grecques
notamment la réforme des retraites on
commence donc à discuter de l'allègement
de la dette grecque même si cela ne
s'est pas fait sans difficulté regarder
affrontements entre manifestants et
forces anti-émeute échange de cocktails
molotov et de gaz lacrymogènes
athènes dimanche dernier devant le
parlement grec
dix mille manifestants venus s'opposer à
la réforme controversée des retraites
une réforme réclamée par les créanciers
européens et le fmi
une réforme adoptée au même moment à
l'intérieur du parlement grec à trois
voix près une courte majorité
153 députés grecs sur 300 ont donné leur
accord à la réforme des retraites
la condition pour que les créanciers
d'athènes versent une nouvelle tranche
des aides du plan de sauvetage négocié
l'été dernier au total
celui ci atteindrait 86 milliards
d'euros avec cette réforme un futur
retraité grecque quelle que soit sa
volonté de gagner plus pendant sa vie
professionnelle ne pourra pas espérer
pour ses vieux jours
plus de 2400 euros mensuels le plafond
maximum fixé par les nouvelles réformes
pour appliquer la réforme les députés
devront voter encore une hausse des
cotisations et la création de nouveaux
impôts
quelques heures plus tard à bruxelles
les 19 ministres des finances de
l'eurogroupe sont tout sourire
ils tiennent une réunion extraordinaire
consacrée à la situation budgétaire de
la grèce
objectif l'allègement de la dette
grecque athènes souhaite la
renégociation comme le fmi
mais pas l'union européenne et plus
particulièrement l'allemagne
changement de ton pour les ministres
européens des finances les réformes
approuvé la veille par le parlement grec
change la donne et ouvre la voie à un
accord sur la dette grecque
même le plus récalcitrant le ministre
allemand des finances est optimiste je
crois que nous allons bien avancé
désormais et je suis toujours confiant
de parvenir à une solution en est même
optimisme du côté de la commission
européenne j'ai dit on
en train aujourd'hui qu'un accord sur la
grèce était nécessaire et aujourd'hui
grâce à une discussion positive
constructive nous avons fait je crois
des progrès très importants vers cet
accord avec les réformes votées par la
grèce sur les retraites le versement de
la prochaine tranche d'adp n'est plus
qu'une question de jours
décision finale le 24 mai prochain lors
d'une nouvelle réunion de leur groupe
alors nous enjoint sur ce plateau robert
rochefort dont jour je vous ai trop
députés de l'alliance des libéraux et
démocrates pour l'europe vice président
du modem en france merci d'être venu à
vos côtés manuel morel bonsoir vous être
député socialiste on vient de le voir ça
y est on va pouvoir alléger la dette
grecque
oui évidemment bon ces réformes il
fallait les faire
elles sont douloureuses à son brutal je
reconnais au gouvernement si prince deux
choses d'abord d'avoir fait des réformes
que les gouvernements précédents y
compris de droite n'avaient pas su faire
et deuxièmement de chercher un peu de
justice sociale le maximum dans ses
réformes maintenant il ya la question de
l'allégement de la dette bon est-ce que
ça se fera sous une forme d'allégement
du nominal où on rallongera encore en
baissera les taux d'intérêt mais ce que
je crois c'est que la grèce n'est pas
pour autant sorti d'affaires ce qui est
important aussi maintenant c'est d'aider
la grèce à retrouver un sentier de
croissance
il faut qu'ils aient de l'investissement
en grèce et ça ça dépend aussi de
l'union européenne donc trois choses des
réformes riz allègement de la dette oui
mais reconstruction d'une économie et
d'une possibilité d'exportation en tout
cas de créer de l'activité andres manuel
moral ces réformes fallait les faire
comme dit aux roches va je répondrai pas
avec le même enthousiasme
ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il faut
remettre la grèce sur le chemin de la
croissance
est ce qu on s'y prend correctement moi
je ne suis pas sûr il ya un espèce
d'acharnement par rapport à athènes et
au gouvernement grec qui vise à dire en
échange d'une aide
on vous demande mais ça c'est
traditionnel dans l'idéologie dominante
de l'union européenne des réformes
structurelles
la première chose c'est que l'aide dont
on parle ce n'est pas une aide qui va
directement la population 95% de cette
aide va aux banques et aux créanciers
donc n'est pas directement redistribués
dans le circuit économique
d'ailleurs toutes les prévisions étaient
démenti on disait ça va relancer la
croissance va relancer l'investissement
grèce c'est le contraire qui s'est passé
deuxièmement on demande aux grecs des
mesures d'austérité toujours
supplémentaires dont l'effet économique
et des as réussi parce que fois les vous
y allez on dresse un logiciel et trois
fois cette année fo rencontrer les gens
la vérité aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a un
pays qui rencontrent une forme de
désastre humanitaire et que et que
l'europe n'en prend pas vraiment
conscience qu'ils aient besoin il est
réfugié qui s'accumulent en plus
creusées réfugie avec d'ailleurs ce ce
chantage absurde heureusement on est
revenus là dessus c'est non seulement
voulait faire le grec site et après on
leur a dit vous n'êtes pas capables de
gérer vos réfugiés par définition vu la
géographie de la grèce arrivent par
milliers et on va vous sortir de
schengen
vraiment on a on a quand même un peuple
qui souffre considérablement le seul
point positif que je vois par rapport à
ce sommet c'est qu'enfin la question de
la dette grecque et sa restructuration
possible est sur la table c'est le seul
point positif que je vois mais la
réalité économique quand même du pays
c'est que ça va pas très bien de même de
plus en plus mal pourquoi parce qu'il ya
cette espèce d'acharnement osterrieth
air qui n'honore pas l'europe qui nous
aident à y aller pas la seule nous n'en
revient tout le temps n'oubliez jamais
c'est l'arlésienne et et notamment lors
lorsque monsieur morel parle du fait qu
on donne de l'argent aux banques
n'oubliez jamais que quand on prête de
l'argent les gens qui prêtent de
l'argent y compris les européens qui
mettent de l'argent dans les banques qui
prêtent de l'argent aux grecs ont envie
de récupérer cet argent
donc on ne peut pas dire comme ça qu'on
supprime et c'est la même chose pour la
france si on commence à dire qu'on
supprime la dette
ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens qu'on
prêtait de l'argent qu'ils vont est
appauvri à cause de ça donc c'est pour
ça que il faut réformer il faut
maintenant réduire cette dette il ya
différents les spécialistes vont trouver
des formules
heureusement qu'on en arrive enfin à
cette solution mais au moins le point
sur lequel nous sommes d'accord c'est
que ça ne suffira pas il faut relancer
l'activité la croissance
je pense quand même que l'année
prochaine la croissance va revenir en
grèce lentement mais ce sera
certainement quelque chose de positif
dans la croissance alors plus
généralement en europe avec la crise qui
dure
la situation des salariés en europe
s'est dégradée ces dernières années le
chômage a baissé dans la zone oi je
crois qu'il est de 18 5% mais il touche
1 européen sur dix en âge de travailler
partout les réformes du droit du travail
se traduisent par une hausse de la
précarité une baisse des rémunérations
et des prestations de l'état providence
un des retraites comme on l'a vu en
grèce est ce que l'europe allait encore
social aujourd'hui messieurs
ou est ce qu'elle a déjà été c'était
c'était un marché économique au début
ben on mettait une europe économique est
ce que l'europe l'europe elle reste
sociale mais la vraie question c'est
est-ce qu'elle a déjà été
il ya incontestablement des la
convergence budgétaire la convergence
monétaire on est dans l'euro mais le
principal absent de la construction
européenne mais depuis le départ c'est
la question sociale
on est d'ailleurs toujours très prompt
pour inciter les états à être toujours
plus disciplinés sur les questions
budgétaires
toujours plus orthodoxes par rapport aux
questions des déficits et de la dette
mais on n'a aucune exigence sur les
questions sociales retraites salaires
temps de travail droit du travail
or c'est précisément ça qui fait que les
gens se détournent de l'europe le sujet
et vous le savez bien c'est que les pays
n'ont pas voulu que l'europe s'occupe du
social c'est pas l'europe qui ne veut
pas s'occuper du social ce sont les pays
n'oubliez jamais que la france y compris
la france quelle que soit d'ailleurs le
gouvernement qu'ils soient de droite ou
de gauche a toujours considéré que son
modèle social était tellement bon qu'il
fallait surtout pas que l'europe s'en
occupe
et c'est pareil pour l'allemagne c'est
pareil pour l'angleterre et c'est pareil
pour tous ces pays
autrement dit dans les traités européens
nous n'avons pas le droit de nous
occuper du social et c'est pour ça que
je crois qu'effectivement une europe
responsable demain devrait petit à petit
avoir des critères de convergence en
particulier sur l'assurance chômage est
quelque chose qui devrait petit à petit
arrivée est proche mais mais n'accuse
n'accusons pas l'europe de ça c'est des
pays qui ne veulent pas c'est l'égoïsme
national comme toujours
ceci étant dit il n'empêche que il ya
quand même quelque chose de frappant
c'est que sans cette convergence décidé
de façon centrale toutes les réformes
qui sont faites en europe depuis la
grande crise récente de 2008 vont dans
le même sens c'est à dire et d'ailleurs
la loi elle comrie en france n'a fait
que reprendre a fait son marché parmi
les réformes qui ont été testées
avant d'en dire aux mises en place dans
les différents pays qu'il s'agisse de
l'allemagne il s'agisse de nathalie et
c'est donc malgré tout il ya une
convergence mais ce que je regrette
c'est cette convergence soit en ordre
dispersé parfois on baisse les salaires
parfois on change le contrat de travail
parfois n'autorise de licenciements plus
faciles on le fait un peu en ordre
dispersé mais tout va dans le même sens
en effet on va toujours dans le même
sens mais c'est toujours le moins disant
social c'est bien tout le problème
européen parce que en effet la
responsabilité des états membres
compass voulu mettre la question sociale
dans l'agenda européen mais la vérité
c'est que il ya une idéologie de la
construction européenne ce soit la
commission ou dans d'autres institutions
qui considère que le progrès ça consiste
à faire en sorte qu'ils aient de moins
en moins de protection leur demande et
avoir du temps mais hélas blair g odeurs
ses droits
si vous considérez que en europe tout le
personnel politique aux affaires qu'il
soit de droite qu'ils soient du centre
où qu'ils soient de gauche à tort ça je
vous renvoie simplement la chose c'est
un petit peu compliqué si vous dites
même quand c'est la gauche ça ne va pas
et repenser la droite ça me va pas non
plus qui vous va non je voulais je
voulais qu'on regarde ensemble l'exemple
l'exemple on va en parler manuel morais
mais regardons l'exemple suédois pendant
ce temps une partie de la suède test la
semaine dès 30 heures un nom ce pas une
blague
vous avez bien entendu six heures de
travail par jour au lieu de huit c'est
le cas en particulier dans des
entreprises ou des services municipaux
de la ville de göteborg en reportage
dans la deuxième ville de suède
c'est lille martel
il est midi et ce mécanicien dans un
garage toyota de la banlieue de göteborg
a déjà terminé sa journée de travail
c'est vraiment un avantage de pouvoir
partir si tôt
j'ai le temps de faire du sport de
courir de faire du vélo je peux faire ce
que je veux c'est vraiment agréable
magnus ou liste rome a beaucoup de temps
libre
car comme les 90 employés de ce garage
il ne travaille que six heures par jour
30 heures par semaine payés 40
dans cette entreprise depuis 13 ans on
travaille moins longtemps pour le même
salaire
et ça fonctionne pour magnus
la clé c'est la productivité il est
réparé autant de voitures en six heures
qu avant 8 heures nous sommes plus
productifs maintenant plus concentré
nous n'avons plus toutes ces pauses les
pauses café les pauses déjeuner nous
avons une seule pause nous gardons un
bon rythme de travail
je pense que c'est surtout ça le patron
confirme l'activité du garage a même
augmenté
maintenant deux équipes se relaient dans
l'atelier une le matin et une l'après
midi nous sommes ouverts 12 heures par
jour sans interruption au lieu de 8
heures auparavant
nous pouvons servir plus de clients et
donc gagner plus les profits du site ont
augmenté de 25%
les deux premières années une recette
originale pour plus de rentabilité qui a
fait ses preuves dans ce secteur
mais la semaine de 30 heures est-ce
possible aussi dans les services publics
en suède la mairie de göteborg deuxième
ville du pays a lancé une
expérimentation inédite dans une maison
de retraite gérée par la commune
ici comme chez toyota les 64 aides
soignants sont passés de 40 à 30 heures
de travail hebdomadaire sans changer de
rémunération après un an
tous saluent l'initiative et se disent
plus épanouie pour arturo perez père
célibataire de trois enfants cette
semaine allégée est une bénédiction
c'est merveilleux d'avoir plus de temps
avec sa famille je peux m'occuper des
enfants les voir grandir les accompagner
à l'école et je me sens aussi plus
serein avec mes collègues et avec les
pensionnaires
la directrice de l'établissement a
commandé une étude d'impact sur cette
diminution du temps de travail
les résultats après douze mois sont
encourageants nous avons constaté une
baisse des arrêts maladie notre
personnel est en meilleure santé est
moins stressé cela a un effet direct sur
la qualité du travail
les aides soignants organisent plus
d'activités pour les résidents une
meilleure qualité de vie pour les
employés pour les personnes âgées
mais à quel prix pour compenser la
réduction du temps de travail
quatorze postes ont été créés pour un
coût total de 600 mille euros par an une
facture qui commence à peser sur les
comptes de la mairie pour maria rieden
élus d'opposition membres du parti
conservateur
la semaine de 6h est un gouffre
financier
mais ce sera réglé et que le look d'un
site web est une idée de la gauche
quand on regarde l'économie des autres
pays comme la grèce l'espagne ou
l'italie
on ne peut qu'être inquiet si on
continue de mener des projets comme ça
si on applique ce projet aux 53 mille
employés de göteborg
si on leur permet de travailler 6
harper 8 je suis sûr que dans un an ou
deux on saura dans la même situation que
ces autres pays européens les défenseurs
du projet des sociaux démocrates
majoritaires au conseil municipal met en
avant les économies que pourrait
réaliser l'état de ce qu'est ce que nous
avons créé permet de diminuer le chômage
et donc son coût pour l'état c'est aussi
une diminution des frais de santé car la
qualité de vie augmente de et pour que
cela marche à grande échelle il faut que
ces économies réalisées par l'état soit
redistribué aux communes de christine
coste sans une aide de l'état l'an
prochain la municipalité de göteborg ne
poursuivra pas l'expérience
arturo et les autres aides soignants
devons retourner à la semaine de 40
heures
si les 30 heures font leurs preuves dans
le privé les services publics de
göteborg n'ont pas les moyens
voilà portage en suède au celi de martel
la réduction du temps de travail c'est
la solution pour lutter contre le
chômage
c'est une des solutions d'ailleurs vous
voyez c'est intéressant par rapport à la
première partie de l'émission il n'y a
pas que des préconisations en termes de
baisses de salaires flexibilité du
marché du travail il ya d'autres
réponses qui doivent être mises dans le
débat la réduction de france nice est
pas la révolution depuis un siècle temps
de travail baisse mécaniquement sous
l'effet de la robotisation ça me fait
des gains de productivité et moi ce que
je veux ce qui est intéressant dans
votre reportage le dit très bien le
l'adjoint au maire de göteborg je peux
pas rentrer dans le détail mais à partir
du moment où ça contribue à réduire le
chômage
ben c'est mieux pour l'état pour les
finances publiques et pour les gens en
tout cas c'est une solution qui doit
être discutée or le problème sur la
réduction de son travail aujourd'hui et
notamment en france c'est parce que là
la droite et le patronat ont poussé des
cris d'orfraie tellement spectaculaire
sur les 35 heures aujourd'hui on ose
plus en parler de peur d'être taxé de
d'arcalis de ringardise les critiques
habituelles mais la vérité c'est que
c'est une solution une solution parmi
d'autres
évidemment mais une solution est ce que
je regrette c'est que ça soit pas à
l'agenda des débats européens
alors vous n'êtes pas d'accord dans tout
ça est totalement faux jeu
pourquoi parce que regarder à nouveau ce
reportage je patiente un jour regarder
le à nouveau qu'est ce qui est
intéressant sur les services publics
on nous dit ça coûte plus cher tout le
monde l'aura deviné il faut que l'état
compense à la mairie l'état dit on va
pas compenser donc l'année prochaine
c'est fini mais regardez dans le secteur
privé
moi je suis pour ce qu'on a vu là parce
que ça c'est une initiative locale fait
dans une entreprise
toyota est d'ailleurs je trouve que tout
les systèmes qui peuvent permettre aux
entreprises primées de négocier
localement des accords y compris du
réduction du temps de travail c'est très
bien mais qu'est ce qu'on nous a dit
dans ce reportage on nous a dit que il
fallait que le salarié de toyota face en
30 heures la même chose que ce qu'ils
faisaient avant quarante heures plus de
pros c'est à dire encore plus de
productivité et c'est là le drame
moi je dis aux salariés français qui
nous écoutent là est ce que vous êtes
d'accord maintenant pour qu'on passe
comme on l'a fait de 39 à 35 de 35 à 30
mais attention vous allez faire la même
chose que ce que vous faites en 35
or tout le monde sait qu'en france le
fait de passer de 39 à 35
justement c'est traduit la plupart du
temps par le fait qu'il fallait faire la
même chose en moins d'heures et qu'est
ce qui s'est passé du coup beaucoup plus
de stress au travail et une augmentation
du chômage parce que tous ceux qui n'ont
pas la capacité d'avoir la productivité
qu'il faut ils sont mis dans la trappe
au chômage et c'est ce qui fait qu'en
france les 35 heures ont comme ça crée
du chômage malgré des chiffres qui nous
ont dit extrêmement le contraire moi je
suis pour que tout le monde ait sa place
dans le mythe dans le travail et qu'on
n'ait pas simplement une société qui
sous prétexte de réduction du temps de
travail ne laisse sa place qu'au super
productif que ceux qui sont plus jeunes
que ceux qui sont plus diplômés ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire la course
à cette productivité la 30 heures pour
faire aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait en
trente cinq heures moi je vous le dis
très clairement je ne connais pas
beaucoup de salariés en france qui sont
prêts aujourd'hui à relever ce défi mais
vous êtes un brin caricatural comme
d'annoncer ce qui es tu sûr thouars le
corps et surtout les chiffres des tares
les chiffres quand ça vous arrange vous
les mettez en avant deux pas du tout
quand ça vous arrange pas se dire que
concrètement les 35 heures c'est la
seule mesure dans les vingt dernières
années pour regagner fait gagner de
l'emploi en france
il faut regarder cette réalité là et
ensuite là où je ne veux
vous suis pas du tout c'est précisément
si on réduit le temps de travail c'est
pas pour que l'on travaille deux fois
plus dans un temps réduit et c'est resté
pour toyota et mais c'est parce qu'on
n'embauche plus de gens mais c'est parce
qu'envoyer un caillou taille a pas plus
de salariés empêchés de toyota
travaillent en général dans les usines
et c'était le cas en france il y avait
plus de gens donc moins de chômeurs pour
réaliser le même travail ensuite je
m'excuse
la réduction du temps de travail et
contrairement à ce qu'on dit c'est tout
le contraire c'est moins de stress cd
meilleure conscience qu'on a visités
dans les meilleures conditions au
travail
donc c'est au pillage là je vous trouve
un brin caricatural vous ne l'êtes pas
les suivre id messieurs et il faut pas
avoir une lecture comptable des choses
mais c'est une seule c'est une des
solutions c'est pas la seule mais en
tout cas on doit être mise en débat
contrairement à ce qui a été dit elle ne
l'est pas en tout cas la tendance en
europe partout en europe est à la
réforme du marché du travail
ça se traduit par une réforme du droit
du travail ça a commencé en allemagne au
début des années 2000 avec gerhard
schröder et les fameux mini jobs a payé
400 euros à les lois hartz en italie à
matteo renzi toujours donc social
démocrate introduit le job act sa mesure
phare un nouveau contrat de type cdi
contrat à durée indéterminée mais
l'entreprise peut se débarrasser du
salarié plus facilement on va vers cette
voie là un plus de flexibilité
protection en europe et c'est clair il
ya unanimité sur ce sujet il ya deux
stratégies pour y arriver il ya deux
stratégies qui sont d'ailleurs assez
différente si vous regardez en allemagne
ce qui s'est passé c'est que on a
également décentralisé la négociation
dans les entreprises comme d'ailleurs la
loi elle comrie envisagent de le faire
dans ce fameux article 2 qui est de
donner la priorité aux accords
d'entreprises alors ce qui s'est passé
est ce qu'on voit en europe c'est que il
ya des endroits où on d'une certaine
façon on détricote le droit du travail
où il ya des endroits où on réduit le
coût du travail ce qui n'est pas tout à
fait la même chose dans les deux cas de
figure
qu'est ce qui s'est passé autour de nous
on a des pays qui sont devenus plus
compétitifs et le drame de la france le
drame de la france c'est que comme nous
n'avons pas fait nous ces réformes
eh bien nous devenons moins compétitif
que nos coûts nos voisins et on estime
aujourd'hui en france que sur un taux de
chômage de l'ordre de 10 à 10 ennemis ça
dépend comment on calcule en france on
estime qu' au moins 2% de ce taux de
chômage pourrait le mettre à 8%
on avait la même compétitivité que les
pays qui sont autour de nous ce que je
veux dire c'est que quand j'entends
aujourd'hui le gouvernement socialiste
ou françois hollande qui disent ça va
mieux
en fait ça va moins mieux qu'ailleurs et
si vous regardez aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe en italie ce qui se passe en
espagne
la france est en train de perdre des
marchés par rapport à l'espagne par
rapport à l'italie elle avait perdu à
l'exportation par rapport à l'allemagne
est déjà assez longtemps parce que ces
pays font des réformes qui vont dans un
sens effectivement qui est un sens de
faire en sorte que la production de
richesse plus facile avec leur choix
pour des souvent elle est noire au
royaume uni par exemple loin avec les
contrats zéro heure un salarié peut être
lille centristes qui ne lui permet pas
loin une seule heure de travail par par
semaine ni aucun salaire minimum
d'efforts quand même plus loin je vous
la corde trop loin d'abord il ya
unanimité sur rien du tout monsieur
ressort ne présentent des évidences là
comme ça tout le monde dit que tout le
monde prend vis de l'alcool mais
évidemment gars je suis pas le seul à le
regarder l'espagne julien vanni reçu
c'est pas vrai là aussi il ya un débat
il ya plein d'économistes sérieux des
patrons aussi parce que ça c'est la voix
du medef mais il ya aussi le petit
patronat qui vous expliquent que le son
obsession c'est pas la flexibilité
c'est plutôt par exemple que les carnets
de commandes se remplissent donc c'est
une action sur la demande une action sur
la compétitivité hors coûts une action
sur l'environnement économique ça c'est
la première chose deuxième chose c'est
quand même hallucinant de prendre les
exemples italiens espagnols en disant
regardez ça va mieux
il faut voir d'où ils partent aussi
c'est sûr qu'en espagne il est à 25%
chômage ils ont baissé à 20% et
d'ailleurs les études en espagne elles
mêmes elles montrent que et en italie
c'est pareil la baisse du chômage n'est
en rien imputables à des réformes de
flexibilisation mais c'est surtout à la
baisse des taux d'intérêt qui étaient
énormes et qui ont messi
grâce à un communiqué ghazi a dit qu'il
avait créé 500 millions près avec sa
réforme et c'est pas vous qui allez
choisir mes amis munich et mais moi je
vous parle de votre ami monsieur draghi
c'est sa politique monétaire intelligent
pour une fois au niveau de la banque
centrale européenne qui fait que ça
desserrer un peu l'étau d'intérêt
notamment dans ces pays là où ils ont
crevé parce que
faut voir aussi que l'italie l'espagne
vite c'est formidable mais ils n'ont
toujours pas retrouvé leur niveau
d'emploi d'avant la crise de 2008 ce qui
n'est pas le cas de la france était là
que nous on a en effet un modèle social
cinglé spécifique mais qui quand il est
confronté à des crises de grandes
ampleurs permet quand même de résister
mieux que les autres
mieux que les autres moi je vais pas
dire ça va pas mieux n'est pas de
répartie et c'est tout le débat
la pression c'est comme un repas et moi
je pense que pour repartir c'est une
politique intelligente d'investissement
c'est une politique intelligente
d'action sur la demande mais aussi sur
l'offre mais aussi sur l'offre ça a été
fait le point de cesser totalement
déséquilibrée les deux et vous est
centriste moi en tout cas je pense qu'il
faut avoir une politique équilibrée
or elle est incroyablement déséquilibré
c'est tout le problème mais aussi c'est
le problème parce que on prend le départ
de l'angleterre il ya parce qu'il ya
langues l'angleterre qui va bien mais
aussi l'angleterre qui va plus du tout
et ce sont des millions et des millions
de gens qui sont enfermés dans la
précarité dans la pauvreté
à terme ça crée un problème pour le pays
l'allemagne elle même qui est érigé en
modèle vais quand même aujourd'hui des
livres qui sortent y compris en
allemagne qui m'intéressent qui disent
attention le modèle allemand quand vous
avez un tel niveau de pauvres et de
pauvreté de gens qui s'est quand même
quelque chose qui devrait vous
intéresser si la pauvreté augmente
oui mais en allemagne c'est
spectaculaire c'est beaucoup là je vous
parle du modèle allemand soit disant
porté aux nues
la réalité c'est que c'est pas si simple
donc là encore et vous dites il ya
unanimité il ya unanimité sur rien il ya
des liens des débats aujourd'hui a quand
même un progrès en europe à celui des du
salaire minimum al smic c'est une
installation c'est une institution en
france et vient de faire son apparition
en allemagne a depuis le 1er janvier un
salaire minimum de 8 euros 50 par heure
de travail
il n'y a pas eu destruction d'emplois de
hausse du chômage avec cette réforme est
bien sûr pourquoi parce que l'allemagne
qui est pas mon modèle c'est à dire il
ya plein de choses qui marchent pas bien
en allemagne en particulier l'allemagne
aujourd'hui ne relance pas assez
l'activité au niveau européen donc ne me
faites pas dire qu'il ya un modèle qui
existe quelque part il n'existe nulle
part simplement arrêtons d'avoir des
ornières
il faut regarder ce qu'il fait autour de
nous alors si vous prenez l'exemple de
l'allemagne l'allemagne
effectivement a fait ses réformes dix
ans avant nous elle en a bénéficié
et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait maintenant
effectivement elle met un salaire
minimum
elle met un salaire minimum c'est une
très bonne chose je souhaite qu'un
seller minimum partout comment dire en
europe mais et si l'allemagne
aujourd'hui vous allez me dire c'est pas
le même sujet mais je crois que c'est le
même sujet si l'allemagne aujourd'hui à
une position sur les réfugiés les
réfugiés qui est beaucoup plus comment
dire qu'ils mois pour moi sauve
l'honneur de leur par rapport à la
position y compris de la france c'est
parce que l'allemagne généreux parce que
l'allemagne a fait des réformes qui lui
permet d'avoir cette politique d'accueil
même si c'est pas simple non plus et en
réalité voilà ça prouve simplement que
effectivement la réforme du travail
n'est pas suffisante
elle c'est pas ça qui va faire en sorte
que l'europe soit offensive il faut une
politique également de grands projets en
europe il faut que dans le numérique il
faut que dans beaucoup de choses on y
arrive mais ne faisons pas l'impasse sur
les réformes du marché du travail et
vous avez beau me dire monsieur morel
que c'est pas y anime comme en europe si
que les gouvernements soient de droite
qu'ils soient de coalition avec de la
droite et de la gauche où qu'ils soient
majorité de gauche
il y à une convergence est incontestable
dans les mesures qui ont été faites par
exemple le contrat de travail unique la
possibilité de mettre fin au contrat de
travail si jamais il y a une difficulté
économique dans l'entreprise encore une
fois les dispositions prévues dans le
rail comme ris et détesté ailleurs on
passe par le 49 3 en france est
difficile de de légiférer là c'est
désastreux désastre politiquement
désastre économiquement en france non je
reviens pas sur la france premièrement
un l'allemagne sur les réfugiés et
rapidement salon daomé d'accord mais je
vous trouve un petit peu hasardeuse
parce que c'est sur c'est bon pour des
raisons démographiques
deuxièmement ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'allemagne c'est que ces ongs et la
malheur on y croise et orgue et la
merkel elle même qui dit on a un
problème de demande en allemagne et il
faut donc redonner du pouvoir d'achat à
ceux qui n'en n'ont plus qu'ils en ont
perdu assez dire précisément quand on se
le faire il faut le faire c'est très
bien mais on aurait la paix de la
grandeur et c'est durant réfléchir avant
troisième chose sur la question du
salaire minimum moi je souhaite avant
d'arriver la monnaie unique on avait un
serpent monétaire européen qui est qui
incarnait un peu l'idée d'europe pour
les gens je souhaite ça soit la même
chose pour le social et pour le salaire
réfléchissons à un mécanisme de
convergence sociale progressif ou la
question du salaire minimum soit porté
dans tous les pays je suis là ça de ce
point de vue là d'accord sarron
renouerait un petit peu
avec l'idée d'un progrès en europe qui
manque tant aujourd'hui est enfin là où
je rejoins votre autre invitée pour la
fin de cette émission c'est que si
l'europe se lance pas dans une relance
tous azimuts d investissement public
privé dans le développement durable dans
numérique avec un peu de vision
prospective
je pense qu'on va au devant de graves
déconvenues et commence à savoir pour
redevenir l'eau d'heure en heure comme
on veut pas ça je pense qu'il ya là il
ya une voie qui est tracé ce sera le mot
de la fin merci robert rochefort d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en prêt merci à
vous emmanuel maurel ces êtres venus
débattre c'est la fin de repères de la
semaine prochaine vous retrouvez nos
ramadi à cette même place
d'ici là bonne suite des programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires bail